[Music]
i hope you're all doing well this
evening or this morning depending on
where you are in the world watching this
lecture i am your instructor asadullah
ali al-andalusi and i just want to
welcome you again to this course how to
read information literacy for the modern
muslim
this is lesson one
what is information literacy
now prior to getting into the subject
i'd like to remind all of you that you
should have already examined your
syllabus video either in the youtube
playlist or in your moodle template so
please prior to watching this lesson or
if you're already watching this lesson
and you haven't watched the syllabus
video please pause this lecture right
now and go and watch that video and
download your textbook both of these are
necessary in order to pass this course
alright
so with that said i'd like to introduce
you to this lesson with a quick video a
video that i feel truly encompasses
the essence of this entire course and
the value and importance of information
literacy in the 21st century and i hope
it will give you an appreciation for
information literacy and why we are
learning about this subject today and
the video in question that i wish to
show you is about true events that
occurred a couple of years ago and
involved a personal hero of mine by the
name of abdul khadr hidara who is the
head librarian of timbuktu and i don't
want to spoil the story so let's just
jump right into it okay
when al qaeda invaded northern mali it
was only a matter of time before they
started burning books but in timbuktu
one librarian decided he couldn't let
thousands of years worth of history and
literature be destroyed
without a fight
i wasn't expecting anything like this
i mean to be honest i thought i was
going to die right then
i knew they'd be coming for the
libraries next
abdel cotter is above all a bibliophile
he turned timbuk2 into this scholastic
center again
ever since the glory years of timbuktu
the late 15th century to the late 16th
century
there was a tradition of writing books
and trading them these priceless volumes
not only are they physically beautiful
but the subject matter romantic poetry
and sex and astronomy and openness about
science and mathematics though this very
different strain of islam very
dramatically different from the hardcore
wahhabi islam that dominates saudi
arabia and that the wahhabis tried to
export to timbuktu
ancient desert town of timbuktu is under
assault
and in recent days one islamist group
allied with al-qaeda has begun
systematically destroying shrines inside
the mosques
sisiki
i knew that if anyone was going to be
responsible for the manuscripts
it had to be me
abdel cotter calls a meeting of his
fellow librarians and he says we got to
do something
the first step of the process involves
sending volunteers out into the markets
of timbuktu
and methodically buying thousands
of foot lockers of trunks
the second step of the operation
involves packing up hundreds of
thousands of manuscripts in these
libraries into the foot lockers
this has to be done
at night
because there are islamic police making
the rounds all the time
there was so much chaos and looting
going on left and right
people were stealing everything they
could find so we just look like all the
other robbers and thieves
[Music]
the third step involves a massive
movement of these foot lockers from
timbuktu across 606 miles to the capital
bamako which is still in government
hands
where they can be stored safely
we tell people climb on we take you out
for free
you got a truck full of 10 to 15 people
inside they don't stop you they just let
you pass on by
that was our strategy
they enlist the support of the village
chiefs stash the manuscripts in various
houses right on the riverbank and then
boatmen go up the river making this
two-night three-day trip from timbuktu a
french helicopter spotted these trunks
being carried upriver the french pilot
demanded that the couriers on board open
up these trunks to make sure they
weren't smuggling weapons
the helicopter pilot left them unscathed
[Music]
jihadists enter the government library
filled with anger hatred desire for
revenge but they see these shelves empty
they didn't realize it at the time but
they were defeated by a librarian
[Music]
the collection has been moved now to a
single facility in bamako they're all
consolidated in one place they're in
good shape uh they're being digitized
systematically and abnormal cotter's
hope is he can return the books to the
libraries that are now sitting empty
padlocked unvisited
we want to make sure the library network
in timbuktu is rebuilt
in order to receive these texts one day
when peace is reestablished
[Music]
all right then so i hope you all enjoyed
that video and now have a greater
understanding of why i consider abdulkad
haidara to be a personal hero of mine
and someone who
embodies the importance and relevance of
information literacy in the contemporary
period and even within the islamic
tradition
now for those of you who are somewhat
still unconvinced of the importance of
what he did
allow me to reiterate sort of to
summarize
why his actions were necessary and how
they accord with islamic values
especially with regard to knowledge and
information
you see many of the manuscripts that he
saved preserved the culture and history
of timbuktu and all of mali so
essentially he preserved and saved the
only means by which the culture defined
itself and understood where it came from
had he not saved those documents and
they had all been burned hundreds if not
thousands of years of history would have
been lost and much of what we understand
about the people of timbuktu and mali in
general would have also been lost
not only that but we would have lost
important documents detailing how islam
entered that land and how islam changed
the lives of these people and how islam
might be used in the future to change
the lives of these people and what i
mean to say is that he also saved many
manuscripts on the islamic sciences he
saved commentaries on hadith he saved
commentaries in the quran he saved
biographies about scholars and important
politicians he saved treatises on
agriculture and other scientific
disciplines that could very well be used
to comprehend to understand timbuktu's
place in islamic history thereby not
only preserving the culture but also its
islamic heritage which can now be
referred to again to revive that society
into perhaps another golden age we don't
know
however if we lost that wealth of
information that wealth of knowledge we
would never know
now unfortunately if you wish to learn
more about these events and this
personal hero of mine not many muslims
have written about these events or this
individual it seems as though many
muslims don't really appreciate what he
did unfortunately so the only books that
we have detailing these events and the
life of abdul qatar hidara come from
non-muslims so for example the book the
bad blank librarians of timbuktu written
by joshua hammer now i do apologize for
the title i didn't pick out the title
however due to the fact that muslims
aren't the ones writing about these
events and don't appreciate these events
we have to rely on the works of
non-muslims to show us the value of our
own tradition
now alhamdulillah you are taking this
course on information literacy so you
are the exception to the rule
that said if you can tolerate the title
i do recommend purchasing this book i
own the book myself and it's very good
however a forewarning there is some
western bias therein however it's still
a very good resource to learn about
these events more in detail
moving on i think it is now time to
discuss what we will be learning in this
lecture
so first off we will be discussing
foundational concepts foundational
concepts or basic definitions that you
need to comprehend and retain prior to
moving into more advanced concepts in
this course
afterwards we'll be discussing
information acquisition information
acquisition which is basically the
process or processes behind acquiring
information in various circumstances and
this section is about information
behavior how we as individuals approach
information and how we acquire it
shortly thereafter we will be discussing
the islamic history of information
literacy and just some events within
islamic history and how information
literacy played a role in developing our
civilization
after this we will discuss in more
detail the relevance and importance of
information literacy in the contemporary
period
and finally the most boring part of this
lecture i assure you we will discuss
your assignments and the quiz
all right then so now that we've gone
over the outline for what we will be
discussing in this lesson let's jump
right into section one foundational
concepts foundational concepts
and the first concept we should probably
learn about is information literacy what
is information literacy you know because
that's the title of this lesson is to
find out what information literacy is
right
so what is information literacy
well information literacy is simply the
ability to find evaluate and use
information efficiently effectively and
ethically to answer an information need
again the ability to find evaluate and
use information efficiently effectively
and ethically to answer an information
need
now that seems simple enough but this
definition can be unpacked a little bit
more
however prior to doing that i want you
to look down below at the fine print
here where it says scott lanning concise
guide to information literacy santa
barbara libraries unlimited 2012 page
two and the reason i want you to focus
your attention on this is because i want
you to know that this is a reference
where i took this information from so
this definition that you see above is
directly taken from this reference
and when we talk about information
literacy we're also talking about where
we acquire the information that we're
using okay and i want you all to know
that anytime that i take from a source
directly i will reference it down below
not only so that you can go and look it
up yourself but also because i want you
to know that i'm taking these
definitions from credible sources now
there will be times in this course where
you will not see a reference and that's
usually because i have not found a
definition that i feel is either
comprehensive enough or is concise
enough for my students so i actually
construct the definition myself based on
my own understanding of the subject and
if you still don't quite understand the
value of providing references in the
near future of this course we will be
discussing the value of references and
why it's effective and ethical to do so
okay
that said let's go back to the
definition of information literacy here
because we need to unpack this a little
bit more in order to comprehend it fully
now there are some aspects of this
definition that we really need to
analyze and the first of those being the
most obvious is what is information
what is information now some of you may
already have an idea in your head about
what information is maybe you have some
background knowledge or maybe for
example you work in the i t field so you
have a particular understanding of what
information is but within information
science there is a specific and
technical definition of information that
we have to follow in order to truly
comprehend what information literacy is
and what is that definition
well information is simply data which
has been recorded classified organized
related or interpreted within a
framework so that meaning emerges again
data which has been recorded classified
organized or interpreted within a
framework so that meaning emerges
so for example a piece of information
would be the following
the year 2020 which happens to be the
year that this lesson was published
that said this is a piece of information
because it conveys the meaning of a
place in time and it conveys that
meaning through the framework of the
english language as well as the
gregorian calendar
so that leads us to the next question if
this is information then what is data
because it appears as though data makes
up information so then what is data
data is simply defined as unprocessed
symbols and experiences or you could say
raw symbols and experiences and what do
we mean by this well if information is
data which has been recorded classified
etc within a framework so that meaning
emerges then data is simply meaningless
bits or aspects which have yet to be
contextualized within a framework in
other words anything that has no context
behind it for example the numbers to 0
to 0. now immediately upon seeing these
numbers you may be tempted to say this
is the year 2020. however that's not
necessarily the case because these
numbers have yet to be contextualized
they have yet to be put in a framework
where that sort of meaning emerges these
are just four random numbers i mean they
could be the year 2020 but they could
also convey other sorts of meaning like
monetary value for example this could be
twenty dollars and twenty cents it could
be two thousand and twenty dollars or it
could even convey the meaning of being
the last four digits of a phone number
or identification number they could be
the middle four digits of a phone number
or identification number and these
numbers may not even be in the right
order maybe it's not 2020 maybe it's
0-2-0-2
maybe it's 2002 we don't know so until
we see these numbers organized in such a
way that meaning comes out of them we
cannot say for certain that this is
information we can only say that this is
data and this goes for other symbols as
well so for example you could have a
random assortment of letters right we
cannot say that this is information
and data is not simply uncontextualized
symbols but can also be uncontextualized
experiences in general so for example
imagine that you go outside because you
hear a bunch of strange noises and you
decide to investigate
now those noises you're experiencing if
you have no idea what the context is and
you have no idea what they represent so
for example are the noises from an
animal are the noises from construction
equipment are the noises from an
airplane are the noises from a car etc
etc if you don't know what those noises
are if you can't contextualize them then
that in fact is simply data
so now that we know what data is let's
go back to the definition of information
so now we know that information is data
or unprocessed symbols and experiences
which have been recorded classified
organized related or interpreted within
a framework so that meaning emerges in
other words information is data that has
been processed within a framework so
that meaning emerges okay
although i think we've come to an
understanding regarding information many
individuals tend to conflate information
with knowledge especially in the
contemporary period when we have so much
access to information many people tend
to believe that because of that access
because they have that wealth of
information at their disposal they are
somehow knowledgeable however this is an
erroneous assumption to make because
information and knowledge are not the
same things
let me give you an analogy
imagine that you walk into a library and
you see thousands and thousands of books
before you now immediately upon entering
the library you understand all of these
books contain information however it
would be incorrect for you to conflate
that with knowledge because you know for
a fact that even though these books
contain information you don't actually
know the information they're in in other
words you have not understood and
retained all of that information so by
bringing up analogies like these you can
immediately see that there's a
difference between information and
knowledge so then what is knowledge well
knowledge is defined as information that
has been understood and retained again
knowledge is information that has been
understood and retained and in actuality
the definition that i've given you here
is a concise summary of the islamic
perception of knowledge the more
comprehensive definition of which has
been defined by the contemporary muslim
philosopher sayed muhammad nabalatas one
of my teachers and the teacher of my
teachers and he defines knowledge from
the islamic perspective as such
knowledge is both the arrival of meaning
in the soul as well as the soul's
arrival at meaning in this definition we
affirm that the soul is not merely a
passive recipient like the tabula rasa
which is latin for blank slate but is
also an active one in the sense of
setting itself in readiness to receive
what it wants to receive and so to
consciously strive for the arrival at
meaning meaning is arrived at when the
proper place of anything in a system is
clarified to understanding so this is a
more complex definition of what i've
just given you and we will be returning
to side mohammed niki balatas in the
near future especially within this
course when we discuss adam and he will
be brought up as a reference in future
courses on the andalusian project
especially when we discuss islamic
epistemology or theory of knowledge
so now that we understand information a
little bit more and the aspects of
information how do we understand the
relationship between data information
and knowledge
and for that i've constructed a diagram
which i think represents a relationship
pretty accurately in that it is really a
three-tier hierarchy
so in the middle you have data and
remember data acts as the building
blocks behind information it makes up
information in that it's like the atoms
or the quantum level of information but
once data has been contextualized once
it's been organized within a framework
to convey meaning it becomes information
it transforms into information so the
data itself changes in a significant way
in that now it can communicate something
to us in that now we can understand what
it is and after the data has been given
context after it's become information
then the process of understanding and
retaining that information comes into
play and that is when information
becomes knowledge
however i want to be very clear here
that the only difference between
information and knowledge isn't the
content or the substance of the
information itself it's more about the
subject who's consuming that information
in other words knowledge is more about
ourselves than it is about the
information itself because the
information doesn't change the content
of the information doesn't suddenly
change when we understand and retain it
it's only our mental state that changes
so although knowledge is included in
this three-tier hierarchy it's not
really a different modality it's simply
a state of mind that we possess about
the information
okay
so now that we understand data
information and knowledge let's return
back to the definition of information
literacy however there's another concept
within this definition that we need to
further analyze the concept of an
information need and what is an
information need how do we define an
information need because we understand
what information is now but what is an
information need well an information
need is simply a recognition that one's
knowledge is inadequate to satisfy a
goal
again a recognition that one's knowledge
is inadequate to satisfy a goal so what
do we mean by this
imagine that you're driving down the
highway and you come across a billboard
and on the billboard it says
6 out of 10 adults in the united states
of america lack information literacy
and
this sticks in your mind as you're
driving and when you get home you decide
to go online and type this information
in a search engine like google and you
try to find any sort of source to verify
whether or not this information is
correct and this scenario represents an
information need in that upon seeing
this information on the billboard you
had the goal of determining whether or
not that information was valid and sound
because you recognize that your
knowledge was inadequate and this is
just one example of an information need
in fact information needs are countless
in that they occur throughout our lives
for example i don't know if many of you
have had the same experience as myself
sometimes you may see a check engine
light on your vehicle right and if you
don't know what the check engine light
is referring to you will try to find
information in order to diagnose the
problem and fix it accordingly
and in this situation you recognize that
your knowledge is inadequate to satisfy
the goal of diagnosing the problem with
your vehicle and fixing it accordingly
so as a result you'll seek out
information to satisfy this goal so for
instance you may refer to the user
manual of your vehicle or you may take
your car to a mechanic
and if you don't have enough money to
take it to a mechanic you may even look
on youtube
another example that may come to mind
are new parents so let's say that you're
expecting to have your first child or
you've already had your first child and
you really don't have any knowledge
about how to be a parent you don't know
how to change diapers you don't know how
to make sure that your child is healthy
and because you want to be a good parent
you recognize that your knowledge about
being a parent is inadequate so you go
searching for information to make sure
that you're taking care of your child
correctly right so maybe you'll call
your parents or you'll call your brother
or sister or you'll call a good friend
who just had a child and has a lot of
experience as a parent or maybe you'll
call your physician and maybe you'll
even go on youtube and look up videos on
how to change diapers and feed a baby
right and there are a number of things
that you can do but the point of all
these examples is to show that
information needs are prevalent in our
lives and this leads us back to the
concept of information literacy you are
taking this course to help you obtain
the ability to find evaluate and use
information efficiently effectively and
ethically to answer an information need
your information need here being to
acquire this ability right so i want to
emphasize that an information need is
not simply a recognition that your
knowledge is inadequate but that your
knowledge is inadequate to fulfill a
goal
okay
and in order to fulfill this goal of
acquiring the ability of information
literacy what we need to try to
understand first is how do we get from
data to knowledge not only do we have to
understand these foundational concepts
but we also have to understand the
process and processes of acquiring
information and what different
circumstances are there in acquiring
information and the right types of
information
and before getting into the specifics we
need to ask certain questions for
example
what is each process in every given
circumstance why is it important to
understand these processes when is it
relevant to understand these processes
what sort of information do we seek
where do we look for this information
and finally how do we navigate the
spaces and mediums where this
information is held and believe it or
not there is actually a science that
helps us to comprehend and answer these
questions and that science is aptly
called information science and how do we
define information science
well information science is defined as
the science that investigates the
properties and behavior of information
the forces governing the flow of
information and the means of processing
information for optimum accessibility
and usability again
the science that investigates the
properties and behavior of information
the forces governing the flow of
information and the means of processing
information for optimum accessibility
and usability and if you haven't already
guessed an information scientist is
simply an expert of knowledge who
investigates the properties and behavior
of information the forces governing the
flow of information and the means of
processing information for optimum
accessibility and usability also
referred to as an information specialist
or information professional that said
there may still be some confusion here
regarding what information science is
and what an information scientist
actually does because the definition is
quite vague so allow me to give you some
examples of some of the specializations
within information science
so among the numerous specializations
within information science i think we
only need to mention a few of them in
order for you to truly understand what
information science is about
the first specialization is probably the
most obvious in that librarians whether
they're a public librarian or an
academic librarian is someone who's kind
of a jack of all trades they kind of do
everything within the information
science field and they can really
fulfill a number of roles so for example
they can work on organizing materials
they can work on preservation they can
also do instruction on information
literacy like i'm doing right now
they can also work as archivists they
can also analyze metadata they can also
catalog etc etc so librarians are sort
of the jack of all trades when it comes
to information science and they're the
number one example one can use whenever
they're trying to understand what an
information scientist does
okay next on this list are archivist and
an archivist essentially organizes and
preserves documents and materials for
organizations so for example if you're
an archivist for a government what
you're going to be doing is preserving
government documents such as historical
documents related to the forming of the
country such as the constitution or the
bylaws preserving historical documents
related to the administration such as
when the last president was elected into
office what they did etc etc so what
archivists essentially do is preserve
the history of the organization they're
working for and they don't just work for
governments they can also work for
companies they can work for hospitals
they can work for universities they can
work for libraries etc etc so archivists
are essential to the functioning of any
organization especially if they want to
understand their past and they want to
preserve the references to justify
current actions or current developments
okay
after that you have metadata analyst and
we won't go into this too much because
it's quite complex but what a metadata
analyst essentially does is they analyze
metadata and they also create data about
data so i know that may seem a little
confusing but essentially a good example
of this is somebody who creates tags for
materials for databases and search
engines so a metadata analyst
essentially describes particular works
particular materials in such a way that
they can be found
so any time that you have a metadata
profile of a particular work they're
going to be key words in there that
allow it to be searched and accessed in
such a way by a system
and this leads us into the next
specialization and that is cataloging
and a cataloger is essentially a
metadata analyst who works specifically
within a library environment and what
catalogers do is that they create and
manage bibliographic records and they
are responsible for organizing and
forming the library's collections and
making sure that patrons and staff alike
are able to find and access the
materials on hand so to give you a
better understanding of what catalogers
do allow me to give you an illustration
and this illustration is from a real
life example and that example is
actually one of my homework assignments
from my cataloging course during my
graduate studies and it's not perfect by
any means there are some minor mistakes
in here however i think it gives us a
pretty good summary of what catalogers
do behind the scenes so as you can see
here this is what we call a
bibliographic work form and this work
form is describing the book the poems
and prose of mary lady chudley so as you
can see there's a number of interesting
symbols and also various numbers but i
want you to focus on the left-hand
column here where there are various
numerical designations and these
designations are essentially codes that
inform the library database about how to
organize and access this particular
material so for example if we look at
the 100 field here and i won't go over
every single one of these but just to
give you an idea if you look first at
the 100 field this is what we consider
the main access point or the primary
means by which this work is organized
and found within a database so the main
way that we find this work is by
referring to the author of these poems
in prose mary chudley who happens to
have the title of lady and another
important piece of information about her
is that she lived between the years 1656
and 1710. that said to define this
particular work more clearly we then
moved down to the designation 245 which
is the actual title of the work in
question and we also include mary
chudley as the author so now this work
the title of this work and mary chudley
from the 17th and 18th century are
directly connected and if we want to
continue describing this work in more
detail we can also include information
about its publication where it was
published what company published the
work and the copyright date we can even
describe the physical aspects of this
particular book and then there's other
designations as well which include more
supplementary data and all of this is
necessary in order to really narrow down
what this work is about and to
coherently place it within the library
collection so that it can be easily
found and accessed
and believe it or not
cataloging was not exactly my forte in
fact it was the most difficult course i
took during my graduate studies and it's
not something i'm really good at because
i'm not really good with like technical
and monotonous work
however that said
i do appreciate and am grateful for
catalogers so the next time you walk
into a library just remember that the
reason that you can find things and that
collections are coherently organized is
because you have catalogers behind the
scenes creating and managing
bibliographic records like this one
okay
all right then so let's move on to
museum curator i mean if you want to
roughly define them they're basically
like the librarians of museums in that
they collect interpret preserve organize
historical materials so as to educate
the public about general history so
whenever you walk into a museum whether
it's an art museum or a museum of
history museum curators are the ones
responsible for setting up the exhibits
and making sure that you have access to
these materials so that you may be
educated about history and they also
work with fossils as well so if you've
ever been to a museum of natural history
where they've displayed dinosaur bones
museum curators are the ones responsible
for setting up those exhibits okay
next on this list are accountants yes
accountants are in fact information
scientists in that they collect
interpret preserve and organize
financial data of individuals and
organizations alike so yes believe it or
not accountants are formally regarded as
information scientists
in the last two specializations that i
mention here i have gone to liberty of
loosely defining as information
scientists because they're not formally
regarded as information scientists and
what i mean by that is historian slash
bibliographers and archaeologists tend
to only be known as interpreters of the
materials they have access to that said
they do often times do more than simply
interpret their materials sometimes they
go out of their way to collect and
preserve those materials especially if
they're working for a museum because
there are actually many historians and
archaeologists who are funded by museums
in order to help with their collections
and oftentimes you may even find
historians and archaeologists who become
museum curators or even museum curators
who also function as archaeologists and
historians okay
now at this point you're probably
wondering to yourself well this is all
very interesting but are there
information scientists within the
islamic tradition and that is a very
good question and the answer is a
definitive yes there are in fact
information scientists within the
islamic tradition and if you haven't
guessed who they are by this point the
best exemplars of information scientists
within the islamic tradition are
scholars of hadith because scholars of
hadith do not simply interpret hadith
they collect narrations of the prophet
muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam and
his companions they organize them
according to validity and soundness and
they go to great lengths to preserve
that material so in many ways hadith
scholars are the quintessential
information scientists of the islamic
tradition and they also act as
historians and bibliographers in that
their work surrounding hadith is really
the foundations behind how we understand
the sunnah how we understand early
islamic history how we understand the
theory of the prophets of allah
and even how we understand many aspects
of islam outside revelation
so yes believe it or not hadith scholars
are our information scientist
and we will be discussing them in more
detail when we discuss the history of
information literacy in information
science in the islamic tradition
however in the meantime let's move on to
section 2 of this lecture information
acquisition
so how do we get from data to knowledge
how do we get from data to knowledge
well that's a very good question and the
answer is not as simple in fact it's
quite nuanced depending on the type of
information that one is acquiring
now before explaining these processes i
want to make clear that information
specialists have already offered several
models and theories regarding general
information behavior which is the
subject's experience with seeking out
information
however we're not going to be discussing
those specific theories and their
complexities because that's not really
the point here rather i'm going to be
explaining how we get from data to
knowledge how we acquire information and
not so much how we seek it our
motivations etc etc so this is a more
general more passive look at how we
consume information and it's more about
the information itself than the
individual so the first process i really
want to start with is the process of
formal information acquisition so what
do we mean by formal information
acquisition well when we talk about
formal information acquisition what
we're talking about is acquiring
information within a formal setting such
as a university or a library okay and as
a result of acquiring this information
within a formal setting most of the
information is going to be formal
information itself or established
information information that comes from
professionals
so how do we go about acquiring
information within a formal setting well
believe it or not we really do not come
to acquire and understand this
information until very late in the
process because much of what we do
within a formal setting is that we are
trusting in the institutions that we're
learning from to give us valid and sound
information
so let's start with somewhat of a
history lesson by examining how formal
information is fashioned and where we
want to begin is far before our time
with the construction of advanced
societies so several hundreds and
thousands of years ago advanced
societies started to form and these
societies began to experience what we
call data okay unprocessed symbols and
experiences and in order to understand
the phenomena around them in order to
understand each other even people had to
start developing language and terms in
order to describe reality and their
thoughts so society started out by
experiencing all of these sounds and
images and especially each other so they
had to start developing means to
understand their world right
so a select group of individuals usually
the community leaders people within
society who are considered to be the
most intelligent or even the most
spiritual begin to record classify
organize and interpret this data through
a specific framework and they start to
transform this data into information now
eventually this specific group of
individuals start to form a culture of
learning to satisfy not only their
curiosity but to also advance
civilization forward so they develop
this culture where they start to advance
language they start to advance education
and eventually this culture starts to
grow to a point where finally these
individuals get together and form a
consensus about particular subject
matters and people within that culture
become more specialized with the
information they have on hand and at
this point you start to see specialists
but even though they're seen as
specialists by the general population
they're not really formalized yet they
haven't been established yet so we're
still in this formative period okay
we're still in this formative period
where people are still trying to figure
out what knowledge actually is so let's
say you have a society who has a group
of individuals who are really well known
for foraging for medical herbs and
they've started to learn through trial
and error how to mend wounds how to heal
the sick etc etc so eventually these
individuals will get together and they
will come to a consensus about what is
regarded as valid and sound information
as factual information as what is
regarded as knowledge and they will get
together and form an information
tradition and what is an information
tradition
well an information tradition is simply
the methods by which a culture of
learning collects records organizes
preserves interprets and disseminates
information i.e the birth of expertise
again an information tradition is simply
the methods by which a culture of
learning collects records organizes
preserves interprets and disseminates
information i.e the birth of expertise
so as a result of forming this
information tradition they have
established themselves as the first
experts of society and this tradition is
usually about a general subject matter
which can contain a number of
disciplines so for example the islamic
tradition of information or you could
even say the islamic tradition of
knowledge within the islamic tradition
there are a number of specializations so
for example the science of hadith the
science of akida the science of fick etc
etc so this tradition encompasses
sub-disciplines as well but even though
a tradition has been formed and the
methods have been agreed upon and the
first experts have been established we
need to understand at this point the
methods that they advance are still
mostly abstract and isolated to an elite
group of individuals who do not
represent the entirety of society so
even though they are recognized as
experts the tradition has not yet really
been made accessible to the general
public so even though they may take on
pupils most of their knowledge is still
not very accessible eventually this
tradition realizes that in order to
preserve itself and in order to educate
the rest of society they need to start
constructing spaces and mediums to
preserve and disseminate this
information that they consider factual
that they consider knowledge
so eventually a tradition will start to
construct information infrastructure and
information mediums and how do we define
these things
so information infrastructure is simply
spaces designed to collect record
organize preserve interpret and
disseminate information
again spaces designed to collect record
organize preserve interpret and
disseminate information
so for example libraries museums
archives and universities universities
often the umbrella for all of the above
and if we examine the contemporary
period we no longer just have physical
spaces but we also have virtual spaces
so the most obvious example of virtual
information infrastructure is the
internet itself and even within the
internet there are subspaces you have
online databases and digital libraries
such as jstor you have digital
encyclopedias like online britannica and
you even have digital archives like the
internet archives which archives web
pages from various websites across the
internet so you can actually use this to
find web pages from several years ago
that no longer exist
and speaking of the importance of
information infrastructure allow me to
quote the information scientist lucron
dempsey when he states the following
archives libraries and museums are
memory institutions their collections
contain the memory of peoples
communities institutions and individuals
the scientific and cultural heritage and
the products throughout time of our
imagination craft and learning and are
our legacy to future generations and i
think this quote is apt because it
should remind you of what happened in
timbuktu and why the librarian
abdulkalhedara and what he did was so
important because he actually saved the
memories of an entire civilization and
preserved them for future generations
so this leads us to discuss what
information mediums are
an information medium is simply the
format whereby information is preserved
and communicated
again the format whereby information is
preserved and communicated so for
example when we talk about what an
information medium is what we mean by
format is is the information physical or
is it digital is it oral or is it
written is it a book or a video
and some of you may be wondering at this
point well what's the real difference
between information infrastructure and
information mediums well the difference
can be seen in two terms and this is the
way you should think about it
infrastructure are the spaces and
mediums are the formats
so infrastructure is like the library
right and the mediums are the books
themselves okay
the information is actually preserved
and taught through the mediums but the
infrastructure is where those mediums
are stored so that's the real difference
here and some of you may also be
wondering well well even though that
makes sense what do we say about virtual
spaces and virtual mediums are they
separated in a similar manner and the
answer is actually yes even though it's
a little bit more muddy because the
virtual space and the virtual formats
can often be confused but in reality
there is in fact a difference between
virtual infrastructure and virtual
mediums so for example let's examine the
lecture that you're watching right now
now what you're watching is a video and
you're listening to an audio recording
right this video is an information
medium now you're watching it maybe on
youtube or moodle and ultimately you're
watching this on the internet so the
spaces or the information infrastructure
is youtube moodle and the internet so
yes those differences do in fact exist
within the virtual environment also
so now let's move on to the final stage
of this process which is knowledge so
the reality here is that the average
person finally acquires this information
after a tradition has been formed and
infrastructure and mediums have been
constructed because society requires
these spaces and these mediums in order
to acquire formal information and only
then does it become knowledge for the
rest of us so even though the tradition
itself considers it knowledge for the
rest of society it's not knowledge until
everything else has been established
prior so for the average person formal
information acquisition doesn't really
happen until the end of the process
now some of you may be wondering about
whether or not revelation can be placed
in this process because as muslims we
also regard revelation as formal
information but we should not call
revelation formal information because
what we typically regard as formal
information is something that is
established by societies and generally
formulated by human beings whereas
revelation comes directly from allah
correct that said the process of
revealed information acquisition is
somewhat similar to the process of
formal information acquisition the only
real difference is that there is no
phase of data and information rather
revelation comes down already as
information knowledge and it's given by
a law to a prophet or a messenger and
then after that there are specific
individuals who follow that prophet or
messenger and they are the ones who form
a consensus about that information and
thus form a tradition a tradition of
information a tradition of knowledge so
in this case it would be the islamic
tradition correct but in the same way as
other traditions of knowledge these
individuals eventually construct mediums
and infrastructure in order to preserve
and spread that knowledge so for example
the infrastructure are mosque and
universities and the mediums are
obviously books such as commentaries and
collections of hadith and just like the
process of formal information
acquisition we acquire this information
near the end
so before going into the next process of
information acquisition i want to
discuss something else that is rather
important and that is the veracity and
relevance of traditions themselves
within the process of formal information
acquisition so as we know human beings
are fallible creatures we are limited in
our knowledge and our comprehension of
reality as a result we tend to make
mistakes in our understanding of the
world and professionals are not immune
to this because they're human just like
the rest of us so how do we trust a
tradition how do we trust a tradition's
framework in preserving and
disseminating valid and sound
information in other words how can we
trust their knowledge if they're just as
fallible as we are well the simple and
what may be considered a trite answer is
that we have no other choice in fact
there are no other options other than to
trust the process because we too are
fallible and we have no better means to
acquiring formal information other than
through professionals and institutions
of learning however unfortunately
especially in the contemporary period
there are many people who have erroneous
opinions about the veracity of
information traditions as well as their
own abilities to ascertain the
information that we have on hand and
what i mean by that is that there are in
fact many individuals out there today
who believe that because they have a
keyboard and an internet connection they
are somehow on par or more knowledgeable
than professional academics professional
medical experts etc and the reason this
is an erroneous opinion is because
although we can admit that professionals
are also fallible and that they can make
mistakes they're usually less likely to
make a mistake because they have more
access to information and they have been
trained to understand that information
properly through a coherent framework
they also happen to have more time on
their hands to focus on these subjects
whereas the average person does not have
proper training nor do they really have
access to the sort of information that
many professionals have access to
despite what they may think because
looking up something on google does not
necessitate that you'll be getting that
information from the right sources nor
that you'll be getting all of the
information and most lay people don't
even know what sort of information
they're looking for nor do they know
where to look and the irony is that much
of the information they're looking for
comes from these experts in fact they
would not have access to this
information had these experts not
uploaded it to the internet for example
through academic databases so it's
interesting when people assume that they
have more knowledge or an equal level of
expertise as professionals themselves
when in fact they would not even have
access to this information had it not
been for the tradition which allows for
this information to be made accessible
online
however i don't want to digress too much
because that's not really the point of
this particular lesson but this
mentality will be touched upon a little
later and in future lessons of this
course that said how do we deal with a
tradition that changes because it is
affected or manipulated in some way or
fashion
so let's look at what happens when a
tradition is compromised or evolves into
something else so in other words let's
look at what happens when a tradition
changes now there are a number of ways
that a tradition can change but the two
main ways are internally and externally
so what does it mean when a tradition
changes internally well what we mean by
this is that it changes through abstract
ideas so when a tradition is established
it has a particular framework through
which it interprets preserves and
disseminates information
now as a result of being constructed by
human beings a framework is obviously
flawed in that it doesn't take into
account data or information it has yet
to experience that may contradict its
overall conclusions or findings so as a
result the future always tells us that
this framework can be challenged and
eventually modified or even discarded
altogether so what do we call this data
or information that can influence a
tradition we call these influencing
factors anomalies and how do we define
an anomaly what is the technical
definition of an anomaly well an anomaly
is simply something different abnormal
peculiar or not easily classified
again something different abnormal
so these anomalies are simply data or
information that the tradition has yet
to experience and cannot fit within its
framework in any coherent fashion in
other words the anomalies undermine the
framework's general conclusions and its
predictive power and as a result of this
some of the professionals within the
tradition start to question the
framework and whether or not it needs to
be changed
so usually this occurs when one or two
or more individuals examine this data or
information that they come across and
cannot explain it on the basis of the
standard framework so what they do is
they try to modify the current framework
or they even try to replace the
framework entirely and if they're
successful in doing so what occurs is
what we call a paradigm shift
so what is a paradigm shift well before
talking about a shift in paradigm we
need to talk about what a paradigm is
but what is the technical definition of
paradigm
well a paradigm is simply a
philosophical and theoretical framework
of a scientific school or discipline
within which theories laws and
generalizations and the experiments
performed in support of them are
formulated and this term was actually
coined by the philosopher thomas kuhn in
his famous work the structure of
scientific revolutions and he also
referred to it as a disciplinary matrix
and just to let you know we will be
discussing thomas kuhn in more detail
throughout many courses here on the
andalusian project especially when we
start discussing epistemology and the
philosophy of science
so now that we know what a paradigm is
what is a paradigm shift
well a paradigm shift is simply the
successive transition from one paradigm
to another via intellectual revolution
again a paradigm shift is simply the
successive transition from one paradigm
to another via intellectual revolution
and as a result of this paradigm shift
new individuals are considered
professionals and the infrastructure
itself also adapts to this change by
changing textbooks and incorporating new
administration and specialists etc etc
to replace the old guard and as a result
what was considered knowledge before is
now regarded as obsolete and the new
information is considered knowledge and
that knowledge leads to a restructuring
of the tradition itself and that
tradition now regards the new paradigm
as a standard paradigm and so the cycle
sort of starts over again now there's
another way that a paradigm shift can
occur and that is externally and what do
we mean by externally well in other
words a tradition can be forced to
change based on some sort of physical
external factor such as politics or war
so for instance a government who
controls the education system can fire
professionals and it may even outlaw an
entire framework if it feels that a
tradition is a threat to its power or it
may influence a tradition through say
funding to force an artificial paradigm
shift for its own benefit and a military
conflict can do likewise
but what a government and a war can also
do is not create a paradigm shift but it
can also try to completely destroy a
tradition and how do they go about doing
this well believe it or not it's not
simply by killing the professionals
within a tradition but by destroying the
legacy of the tradition itself and how
does it go about doing that well when a
government or military really wants to
control a society or destroy its culture
and its people the first thing that it
will do is that it will try to destroy
its memories and bury its intellectual
and technological achievements and how
does it go about doing this
well that's when a military or
government conducts libricide and what
is libricide well libricide is the
systematic destruction of information
mediums and infrastructure often
practiced as a part of ethnicide again
the systematic destruction of
information mediums and infrastructure
often practiced as a part of ethnocide
so essentially burning down libraries
and destroying manuscripts and artifacts
and anything else they can get their
hands on and usually this is the
beginning stage of a genocide
so the most prominent example of that
being within islamic history is when
ellen de luz was finally conquered in
the 16th century by the christian armies
and what they did was they started
burning books and many civilizations in
the past have actually practiced this as
a form of destroying their enemies by
destroying their memories because even
if you kill people if they have their
memories they have a link to the past
but if you remove a people's history and
you remove their identity what you're
essentially doing is that you're causing
cultural amnesia and if you remove the
memories of people especially people who
have been oppressed or destroyed what
then occurs is that they have no need
for revenge and they have no need to
revive themselves as a civilization
because they don't even remember who
they are and as a result of that the
government or military in power can now
write history as it sees fit even to the
point where they blame the victim
and it's even practiced by terrorist
organizations such as al-qaeda as you
may recall would happen in timbuktu
all right then so let's move on to the
final process of information acquisition
and that is the process of informal
information acquisition or what you
could also call general information
acquisition or everyday information
acquisition so basically how we acquire
information in an informal setting in a
non-academic non-professional
environment and in these sort of
settings we can acquire all sorts of
information whether it be from
professionals or non-professionals
however it takes a little bit more
effort because now we're not being
taught we're not being fed information
from a tradition rather we are bombarded
by information from various sources in
our daily lives and we have to put more
effort into ascertaining the validity
and soundness of that information and
for the most part you are taking this
course to understand how to find and
process information in this sort of
setting
all right so let's start from the very
beginning and the first part of this
process is that we come across
information sources whether actively or
passively so the first part of this
process is an information source we
experience an information source and
what is an information source
well an information source is simply a
source from where information is
received
again an information source is a source
from where information is received and
we're discussing information sources
more in the process of informal
information acquisition because this is
where the question of sources becomes
more predominant especially when we're
outside of a professional environment
because as i said earlier in a
professional environment most of the
sources that we get a hold of are
usually guaranteed to provide valid and
sound information or in the very least
we are given support by professionals to
find valid and sound information whereas
in an informal setting the nature of
sources has to be judged by ourselves
and that's the reason we're emphasizing
it more in this process than in the
previous ones
so what are some categories of
information sources well there are three
main categories and they are primary
secondary and tertiary and what do these
mean well a primary source is simply
first-hand information a secondary
source is information about the primary
source
and tertiary is information that
summarizes primary and secondary sources
and here are some examples
a primary source would be like personal
letters written by a historical figure
such as salahuddin a secondary source
would be more like a biography about
salahuddin talking about his experiences
and what he did and an example of a
tertiary source would be an encyclopedia
entry about salahuddin
and an information source doesn't just
have categories but it also has classes
and these classes should be familiar to
you in that this is how we similarly
describe the processes that we're
discussing in this lecture and the
classes are formal and informal
information sources and what are formal
and informal information sources well
you should already know that a formal
source is academically or professionally
recognized and an informal source is a
non-academically or non-professionally
recognized source
so for example a formal information
source would be a textbook on entomology
or the study of insects and the example
of an informal source would be the
personal blog of an insect enthusiast
right because a textbook on entomology
is academically recognized whereas a
personal blog is simply well a personal
blog
now if it were a personal blog of a
entomologist who is in the field
reporting their findings then it may be
regarded kind of enters more of a gray
area because that individual is
simultaneously an expert but the format
that they choose to present their
findings on isn't academically
recognized it's not considered one of
the formal mediums so there is a little
bit of a gray area there
so now that we understand what an
information source is what happens after
that well after experiencing an
information source for example say
watching the news imagine that you're
watching cnn or al jazeera and you come
across a news story okay and it's
information that you have not been aware
of before and they are presenting
stories about what's happening in the
world now there's a number of ways we
can deal with this information but
generally speaking the next part of the
process is that we recognize that our
knowledge is inadequate especially when
we're reading news whether it's on tv
youtube or social media in general what
occurs is that we recognize that our
knowledge about the information coming
from that source is inadequate and
perhaps we want to know more so with the
goal in mind of learning more about what
happened the obvious next phase in this
process is information seeking and what
is information seeking well information
seeking is a conscious effort to acquire
information in response to a need or a
gap in one's knowledge again information
seeking is a conscious effort to acquire
information in response to a need or a
gap in one's knowledge so as a result of
seeking we then attempt to satisfy the
goal that we have in mind whether it's
to ascertain the validity of the
information we've received or to learn
more about that information and of
course the final phase is knowledge now
this seems like a very simple process
but there's actually a lot more here
because there are a number of speed
bumps that can occur along the way so
this seemingly simple process can become
rather complex very quickly and what do
we mean by that well in the information
seeking phase something may occur that
leads us in the wrong direction and that
is something that affects all of us
which is misinformation and what is
misinformation well misinformation is
simply incorrect or misleading
information again misinformation is
information so for example imagine that
you're going through your facebook feed
and you come across a news article from
an unrecognized source but you notice
that it's going viral you notice that
this story is going viral and the story
is about the discovery of a new primary
color and for those of you who read the
first chapter of your textbook you'll
understand the history of this story and
uh how far it actually went
so the story is about a new primary
color that has been discovered so after
seeing this you recognize that your
knowledge is inadequate and you want to
learn more you want to find out if this
information is actually valid and sound
so you go seeking information and in the
process of seeking information you
decide to go on google and you happen to
come across a source that seems to
verify the previous source that you are
reading on facebook however unbeknownst
to you because you're not really trained
to find information to verify
information this source is simply
copying from the previous source and
spreading a false narrative and instead
of checking other sources you are
content with what you have read and you
have therefore consumed misinformation
which does not lead to knowledge so
instead of recognizing that this is
misinformation you instead believe the
misinformation and are led astray
however running into misinformation is
not the only thing that can happen
during this process so something else
that can occur is that our own biases
can play a role in not only whether or
not we receive valid and sound
information but also whether or not we
get through the process to begin with
so for example when coming across
information we can also go through
something called cognitive dissonance
and what is cognitive dissonance well
cognitive dissonance is the state of
discomfort felt when two or more modes
of thought contradict each other the
clashing cognitions may include ideas
beliefs or the knowledge that one has
behaved a certain way those who
experience this feeling may actively
avoid processing information that
conflicts with their beliefs again
cognitive dissonance is the state of
discomfort felt when two or more modes
of thought contradict each other the
clashing cognitions may include ideas
beliefs or the knowledge that one has
behaved a certain way those who
experience this feeling may actively
avoid processing information that
conflicts with their beliefs so for
example if you come across a source that
is distributing information that
contradicts your beliefs some may react
to that not by triggering an information
need and seeking out whether or not this
information is valid and sound or even
trying to learn more about this
information but they may actively
dismiss the information and the source
in order to protect themselves from
going through this process and
potentially changing their minds or
doubting their beliefs and usually the
reason people do this is because they
feel a sense of discomfort from going
through this process and a lot of people
prefer to just simply believe what they
believe and not be challenged about it
because it does sometimes take a lot of
effort and time to examine their own
beliefs to examine the validity and
soundness of information and to process
that information in such a way that they
may challenge their own beliefs so it's
really a defense mechanism from feeling
discomfort with the information that
they come across and one of the things
that this course wishes to prevent is
cognitive dissonance because every
single day we may come across
information that contradicts our beliefs
but in order to truly relieve your
doubts sometimes the best thing to do is
to go through this process
now another bias that many people may
have is what we call the dunning-kruger
effect and this mentality is the one
that we were discussing prior regarding
the sense of confidence that people have
in ascertaining information and this
assumption that they are somehow on the
same level as experts so how exactly do
we define the dunning-kruger effect well
the dunning-kruger effect is defined as
a cognitive bias in which people wrongly
overestimate their knowledge or ability
in a specific area this tends to occur
because a lack of self-awareness
prevents them from accurately assessing
their own skills again a cognitive bias
in which people wrongly overestimate
their knowledge or ability in a specific
area this tends to occur because a lack
of self-awareness prevents them from
accurately assessing their own skills
and unfortunately this is one of the
primary cognitive biases in the
contemporary period and it's something
we'll be discussing in more detail later
on in this course
and one of the other speed bumps that
may occur during this process is that
after experiencing information from a
source recognizing that you have a need
and then going to seek information
because of your inability to find the
right information you may simply not
know whether or not the information on
hand is in fact valid sound and whether
or not you fulfilled your information
need is largely undetermined so all of
these can be blockers in this process
that said there is another way that this
process can go especially when we're
talking about data remember data is
unprocessed symbols and experiences so
if you remember the example we gave
earlier regarding the noises that you
hear outside of your house you can come
to the conclusion that you have an
information need and then go about
seeking what this data is at the same
time however you could be so
discomforted by the idea of finding out
what that data is that you actually
refuse to even engage with it but an
even more rare occurrence is that you
may experience data that has yet to be
processed by anyone and this is a rare
occurrence because usually discovering
new data and transforming it into
information occurs by professionals
especially when we talk about scientific
discoveries and even then when somebody
assumes that they've discovered
something new it tends to be
misinformation because they've misjudged
that the data has already been processed
by professionals however in the event
that they do discover something new the
data that they have processed into
information becomes knowledge and then
becomes integrated into formal sources
so to give you an example of how this
might work imagine that you are an
insect enthusiast and you run a blog
about your love of insects okay
and
so one of the things that you love to do
is that you enjoy collecting and
studying beetles
and uh the reason i bring this example
up is because when i was younger i
actually enjoyed collecting and studying
insects that said even though it's not
my career choice i still find insects
interesting but let's just imagine for a
moment that this is the first time
you've come across this sort of beetle
and you don't know what it is so
although you recognize it as an insect
it really is a form of data because you
have yet to really classify what type of
beetle this is so recognizing that you
have a need to understand what this
beetle is and that you don't have the
information to fulfill this goal you can
do one of two things now first off you
probably go seeking information but
let's assume you've already done this
and you've come to the conclusion that
this beetle has never been discovered
before until you came upon it
okay and as a result of that you decide
that you're going to classify this
beetle yourself and you're going to
submit your classification to say the
foundation of national science or
something so you classify this beetle as
the salahuddin beetle and then you
submit your findings to the national
association and they recognize your
discovery and that becomes actual
knowledge that is then integrated into
formal sources now the other thing that
could possibly happen is that this
beetle has already been discovered
therefore the information you've
constructed is actually misinformation
and is not true knowledge right
so i think these processes are
sufficient for you to understand how we
acquire information and the obstacles
towards acquiring information so now
let's move on to the history of
information literacy within the islamic
tradition
so let's begin to discuss the history of
information literacy within the islamic
tradition and within the history of
islamic civilization and the reason
we're talking about information literacy
within islamic history is because i want
you to understand its importance towards
the development of the islamic tradition
as well as islamic civilization in
general so i think the best place to
start first would obviously be with the
advent of islam itself through the
revelation of the prophet muhammad
and this period is what we consider the
formative period for information
literacy within the islamic tradition
and islamic civilization overall and
what i mean by this is that this is the
first time that revelation is given to
the prophet muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam and not only is he learning
directly from allah but he must preserve
and teach the information that is being
given to him and as a result of this he
fashions a culture of learning among his
companions because what the companions
were doing at the time is that they were
not only memorizing the quran but some
of them were even recording some of the
actions and sayings of the prophet
muhammad himself sallallahu alaihi
wasallam and of course those records and
those memories would eventually become
what we know now as hadith so the
prophet muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam began this culture of learning
began this tradition of information
literacy between himself and his
companions and the preservation of
information was integral to the
beginning of the tradition as well as
the beginning of islamic civilization
and the importance of information
literacy is even emphasized in the quran
itself so for example if we take some
excerpts from the revelation we find a
number of instances where it mentions
knowledge the importance of knowledge
and the importance of learning
information from the right sources so
for example in the quran surah 21 ayah 7
we find the following and we sent not
before you o muhammad except men to whom
we reveal the message so ask the people
of the message if you do not know so the
quran is instructing people to learn
from people of knowledge from people who
are considered authorities on a
particular subject matter and there are
other places in the quran as well that
also emphasize the preservation and
dissemination of information so for
example in surah 9 ayah 122 we find the
following and it is not for the
believers to go forth to battle all at
once for their should separate from
every division of them a group remaining
to obtain understanding in the religion
and warn their people when they return
to them so that they might be cautious
and what we have here is an ayah that
not only discusses the methods of
warfare but alongside that we also have
a command here to preserve and
disseminate knowledge of the religion
itself and the reason i find this rather
fascinating is because you know there
are many people out there who accuse
islam of being this very warlike
religion and that it's all about war and
destruction and violence and that's a
pretty nonsensical opinion and we won't
be discussing it in too much detail here
but what i find ironic about that is
that within this very aya about battle
about the potential for warfare it gives
equal if not more weight to the
preservation and dissemination of
knowledge within the religion in that it
tells the believers that some of them
should stay behind because knowledge
needs to be protected so here we have a
direct command from the quran itself
from allah that the believers need to
give just as much importance not only to
the protection of themselves through
military combat but they also need to
protect the knowledge within that
community they need to protect their
memories and the intellectual tradition
of islam so i find this a really
fascinating ayah in that information
literacy the preservation and
dissemination of information is so
highly emphasized as integral to the
survival of islamic civilization
so after a number of years of the
prophets ministries
he eventually passed away and it was
during this time that the muslim
community was put into a great deal of
chaos in that they didn't really know
who was going to be the next leader of
their community to preserve the religion
to preserve the society they had
developed and eventually a successor or
a caliph was chosen to lead the muslim
community and of course the first caliph
was abu bakr as-siddiq and what's
interesting is that from this point
forward those who had been recording the
prophet's actions and sayings
they started to pass this information
down to their family members and to
other believers within the community so
this culture of learning continued and a
tradition of knowledge a tradition of
information started to be formed and
within this tradition were compilations
of hadith which also emphasize
information literacy so for example if
we look within the hadith compilation of
sahih muslim we find the following
abdullah narrated it on the authority of
his father yahya knowledge cannot be
acquired with sloth and sloth is just a
word for laziness or lack of motivation
to do something in other words you
cannot acquire knowledge without any
effort to verify sources or to seek
whether or not information is valid and
sound so in other words you cannot have
knowledge without information literacy
and another hadith is really interesting
in that it doesn't really speak about
information literacy per se but it's
more of a passive hint so this hadith
states the following narrated yazid bin
umaira when death was upon muad bin
jabal it was said to him o abu
abdulrahman advise us so he said indeed
knowledge and faith or at their place
whoever desires them shall find them and
he said that three times and seek
knowledge from four men and he mentions
these men who were companions of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam and
these individuals were considered
authorities within that culture of
learning that had been developed
so here we see that he's not only
informing people that they need to seek
knowledge with effort but to seek it
from the right sources the right
authorities on this subject matter so
here we see him emphasizing information
literacy and this is not all that
surprising because eventually these
sentiments this understanding of
knowledge expanded out into the rest of
the muslim community and caused a number
of events to occur within the tradition
in islamic history in general and what
do we mean by that well let's skip ahead
a couple of years to the reign of the
third caliph of islam uthman fun and the
reason uthman is a good example here is
because he's technically the first
patron of the preservation of
information within islamic history so
essentially he was the first to provide
government support and funding towards
the project of codifying the quran into
the standard mushaf that we have today
and the reason he did this was because
during his reign many of the companions
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam were starting to pass away
either because of military conflict or
illness or simply old age and the reason
this was problematic is because many of
them memorized the quran by heart and
the only preservation of the quran up
until that point was through
memorization so he decided to create a
fail-safe program that would continue
the preservation of the quran that would
transcend the lives of these particular
authorities so he formed a committee to
bring together all of the known versions
or the compilations of the quran because
at the time it was not organized in the
same manner across different regions and
between different individuals so he
decided to compile all of the
manuscripts that were available as well
as to gather all the remaining
authorities on memorizing the quran and
to make sure essentially to oversee and
validate this codification effort so in
summary uthman became the first patron
of the preservation of information
within the islamic tradition and islamic
history so without his patronage and the
efforts of the community at the time we
would not have the standardized quran
that we have today now if we jump a
couple of decades into the future we see
the beginning of an event that is
triggered by another patron of
information literacy and that is the
caliph abdul malik bin
and what he essentially did was that he
noticed the surrounding empires that
were hostile to the newly established
islamic empire had their own currency
and the muslims at the time were
borrowing that currency as an essential
part of their economy and this was quite
problematic because you can't
simultaneously be attacking your enemies
while using their currency because they
can eventually bankrupt you by
controlling the value of that currency
correct so he decided that it would be
best if the islamic empire began to mint
its own currency however there was a bit
of an obstacle towards this in that the
early muslims didn't really know how to
mint currency they didn't really know
the science of what we call alchemy and
this is the science that had to deal
with melting metals and fashioning
weapons and currency and other sorts of
materials that were needed so he
basically told his aides that he wanted
to collect and begin translating greek
and persian works that taught alchemy
and this is what we call the beginning
of the translation movement and the
reason this is important is because the
translation of books on alchemy
eventually led to muslims especially
within the government to start
translating other greek and persian
works on science and mathematics and
philosophy etc etc because the early
muslims understood that there was a
wealth of knowledge hidden within these
books despite the fact that the
metaphysical views or the religious
views held by those who initially wrote
them were not in concordance with the
values and beliefs of the muslim
population and the reason i bring this
up is because i think it's really
fascinating if you compare the early
muslim community who is far more
religious than the contemporary muslim
community and you compare their
mentality with the muslims of today you
see a very stark difference in that back
then muslims were not afraid to read
other materials to learn other languages
to understand the beliefs and practices
of other civilizations and religions in
other words they were so confident in
their islam in their own beliefs and
values that they were willing to dig
through hundreds and thousands of works
of individuals they considered to be
non-believers just so they could gather
that knowledge within the knowledge they
felt that allah had gifted them with so
essentially they understood that despite
the fact that the overarching systems
that these people believed in were false
that there was still truth to be found
within them to some degree whereas today
you have a lot of muslim leaders and
even spiritual guides who protest the
reading of anything outside of the
islamic tradition who literally try to
ban books and materials that they
consider to be heretical or lead to
disbelief because they somehow feel that
if muslims are to read these materials
or to learn certain subject matters they
will lose their faith but in the past
the early muslim community actually
embraced reading different ideas and
beliefs because they weren't afraid they
did not feel this inferiority complex
when it came to learning acquiring and
preserving and disseminating information
and i think it also had to do with the
fact that information literacy was such
a necessary skill that they emphasized
and alongside this mentality was also
the way in which they collected recorded
and tried to preserve this material for
the masses speaking of these historical
methods the islamic studies professor
angelica neworth stated the following in
an interview by lewis gropp
for a very long time the islamic culture
of knowledge was far superior to that in
the west or outside the islamic world as
a whole this was not least the result of
the fact that the islamic culture was
more advanced in terms of media for
example paper was being manufactured in
the islamic world since as far back as
the 8th century or the 700s this in turn
made it possible to disseminate huge
amounts of text which was definitely not
the case in the west at the time without
a doubt more than 100 times more arabic
texts were brought into circulation
during this period than was the case in
the west right up until the 15th century
or the 1400s people in the west relied
on parchment which was very expensive
and hard to come by so essentially the
muslims had not only developed a culture
of learning but they eventually
developed the technology to facilitate
this culture so for the early muslims
the sciences were really just a tool in
order to facilitate and manifest their
own values
now let's move on to the 8th century
starting in 717 ce with the caliph omar
abdulaziz or omar ii and he is another
patron of information literacy in that
he ordered the codification of the
sunnah or what we know today as the
seerah and the collections of hadith and
shortly thereafter around 719 720 ce a
scholar by the name of shihab azuri was
able to complete this request with one
of the first known compilations of
hadith and various anecdotes of
muhammad's life
and in the process of codifying these
things he laid the groundwork for the
methodology of tracing and validating
narrations so essentially azure has come
to be known as the founder of the
sciences of hadith and seerah and
technically he would be considered the
very first information scientist of the
islamic tradition and of course there
were other muslim information scientists
prior but none at this point within the
field of islamic science
now there are some other events that i
briefly want to go over that play a part
in the islamic history of information
literacy so for example if we jump about
a decade or so that is when the famous
tunisian mosque alsaituna was built and
eventually became a major library and it
is considered to this day to be one of
the oldest libraries in existence and
for those who don't know libraries back
then were also where major scholars
studied and one of the most famous
scholars in islamic history by the name
of ibm khaldoon also considered the
father of sociology he actually studied
and wrote many of his major works in
this mosque now if we move ahead about
50 years or so to 7080 ce the famous
jurist and one of the four great imams
imam malik authored his muata which was
essentially an effort at codifying
islamic law with the use of hadith so
it's essentially considered one of the
first major works on fick and to this
day especially within the maliki madhhab
or maliki's school of jurisprudence one
of the most authentic sources within the
islamic sciences
so let's move into the 9th century and
this is where things start to get even
more interesting in that for most
historians the beginning of the 9th
century is what marked the advent of the
golden age of islam and for the most
part the reason why many historians
consider this to be the beginning is
because this is when the house of wisdom
in baghdad was built and established as
one of the greatest libraries and
universities the world has ever seen and
many of the great islamic scientists
studied here and discovered many things
in this very institution now personally
i would mark the beginning of the golden
age a little bit farther back at the
beginning of the translation movement
because that's what really got
everything started with scientific
productivity and intellectualism within
the muslim world
however just for the sake of convenience
we will follow the mainstream historical
narrative here in that the golden age
started around 800 ce
now what's fascinating about this is
that after the advent of the golden age
many things started to happen within the
islamic sciences and one of the first
major milestones was that in 846 ce imam
bukhari completed hisaki collection and
sahih bukhari is considered to be the
most valid and authentic reference for
islamic knowledge second only to the
quran itself
now before going into the implications
behind this uh let's discuss yet another
event that occurred shortly thereafter
and that was the founding of
mosque by a woman patron by the name of
fatima al-fifri and this mosque is very
special because it's considered to this
day to be the oldest university and one
of the oldest libraries that's still
standing now although today there are
some historians who are questioning
whether or not fatima actually founded
this mosque the vast majority consider
her to be the actual patron and whether
or not she actually did found the mosque
or was only the individual who later
facilitated it to become a university
the fact of the matter is is that it
showcases that historically with an
islamic civilization women played a very
large part in education and supporting
information literacy likewise what it
shows is that muslims generally had no
problem with women in education because
even if she didn't found the mosque or
even if she didn't establish the
university itself the interesting thing
is is that for hundreds and hundreds of
years muslims especially men took no
issue crediting her with its founding
and establishment and in a moment we'll
see another example of a muslim woman
information scientist and i won't ruin
it for you just yet but i just want my
female viewers and my male viewers who
have daughters to know that they should
be very proud of the fact that there is
a tradition of education and patronage
of information literacy by women within
islamic history because without those
women being patrons and being part of
information literacy the golden age
would not have flourished as it did but
i don't want to digress too much so
let's move on to 864ce
when imam muslim completed his sahih
collection in his collection sahih
muslim is considered to be the most
authentic reference after sahih bukhari
so within a span of 60 years we see the
codification of two of the most
authentic compilations on hadith right
after the advent of the golden age of
islam and now the point that i want to
make here is that these codification
efforts by these traditional scholars
were considered to be extremely
religious occurred during a time when
many historians today unfortunately
still have this bias that the golden age
of islam began not in concordance with
religious values but despite them but
that couldn't be further from the truth
because much of the development of the
islamic sciences occurred during this
time so the question is how is it that
the golden age only came about as a
result of apathy to religious values or
on the basis of anti-religious
sentiments when in fact some of the
greatest developments within the
religious sciences themselves occurred
at the very same time the fact of the
matter is it doesn't make any sense
now if we move a little bit farther
ahead and in a different geographical
location let's say 968 ce a little bit
after the founding of al-andalus or
islamic spain and this is a very
interesting time period because a caliph
by the name of alhakam ii the caliph of
cordoba decided to start his own
translation movement and founded one of
the greatest libraries of the world the
library of kotaba and apparently this
library was his personal collection and
it had over 500 000 books and only
rivaled by the house of wisdom itself so
al-haqam ii became another major patron
of information literacy within islamic
civilization and something else that was
interesting about his library was that
it was managed by a woman and this is
the example i wanted to bring up earlier
and the sister who managed those
thousands of works was a woman by the
name of lubna al-kordaba but what's
interesting about that is that again a
woman was put in charge over the
knowledge of alan de luz so imagine that
no one could gain access to knowledge
except through her because she was the
gatekeeper she was the individual who
made sure that the population was
educated because back then again
libraries and universities were one in
the same right so all of the scholars
studied there and they relied on her to
get them references and to manage the
facility so she played a very important
role in information literacy during the
very early period of the andalusian
caliphate so i think that i've set up a
few events within islamic history to
give you a better understanding of how
information literacy fits within our
history and how important it was to the
overall success of islamic civilization
and in preserving our religion and
developing muslim intellectualism in
general however let me briefly go over
some negative events that occurred
during our history as well and this is
during the 13th century when we start to
see some obstacles that pave the way
towards the decline of the golden age of
islamic civilization so if we look just
in the 13th century by itself we find
that the reconquista of al-andalus wears
near its peak and this was during the
time that the european catholics had
begun reconquering al-andalus in the
name of europe and christianity more
specifically and they were committing a
great genocide against the muslim
population and one of the first things
that they did to facilitate this
genocide was by burning the library of
cordoba so essentially the spanish
catholics committed libercide on the
library of cordoba and this was actually
done by ferdinand iii
and they essentially destroyed the vast
majority of that library and only
preserved some of those texts for
themselves so essentially not only did
they destroy the heritage of al-andalus
and the memories of the people who lived
there but they also stole much of the
knowledge that was developed and
produced by those very same muslims now
unsurprisingly shortly thereafter the
mongols sacked baghdad and also
committed liberal side on the house of
wisdom so we lost two major libraries
within a span of two decades in the 13th
century and this is just one among many
factors that led to the decline of
islamic civilization and most historians
even those of a more traditional islamic
perspective essentially regard the 1500s
or the 16th century as being when the
golden age came to an end so it's
unsurprising that one of the major
factors behind the decline of the golden
age was the destruction of our libraries
and our tradition of information science
and information literacy and the reason
i bring this up is because it seems to
me that many muslims today not only do
not value information literacy but they
don't even value libraries and that's
really unfortunate because during the
golden age of islam it was information
literacy and the library institution
which facilitated that golden age and
allowed us to become exemplars the rest
of the world for many many centuries so
perhaps if we want to revive our
civilization we need to give more
attention and focus not only to
education but information literacy and
the information sciences while i
understand that professions like
engineering and medicine and business
are great for building status and carry
with them great monetary value the
problem here is that these professions
seem to be the only ones that muslims
really strive for but muslim
professionals back then were not simply
engineers and medical doctors but today
we tend to look down on people who
choose professions other than the
handful that many cultures have chosen
to value prior to us even being born so
i just want to leave you with that
thought before moving on to the next
section actually prior to that if you're
wondering if there were any scholars who
wrote about information literacy there
were in fact many and in fact we will be
examining one of those texts in this
very course
all right then so let's move on to the
relevance and importance of information
literacy in the contemporary period
all right then so let's move on to
section four the relevance and
importance of information literacy in
the contemporary period and what i want
to look at first is a quote by akbar
ahmed in his book post-modernism and
islam predicament and promise and
therein he talks about the current
global media western media and he states
the following nothing in history has
threatened muslims like the western
media neither gunpowder in the middle
ages which muslims like babar used with
skill on the fields of panipat thus
winning india for his mogul dynasty nor
trains in the telephone which helped
colonize them in the last century nor
even planes which they mastered for
their national airlines earlier this
century the western media are ever
present and ubiquitous never resting and
never allowing respite they probe and
attack ceaselessly showing no mercy for
weakness or frailty the powerful media
offensive is compounded for muslims they
appear not to have the capacity to
defend themselves worse they appear
unable to comprehend the nature and
objectives of the onslaught
so here he was writing in 1992 regarding
western media onslaught in terms of
propaganda against muslim minorities and
the muslim world at large and he's not
necessarily saying that the propaganda
is causing physical harm or violence but
that it's causing violence to the
reputation of muslims in such a way that
it's actually affecting government
policies and it's affecting the way in
which western countries and westerners
more specifically perceive and treat
muslims and we as muslims because we're
a minority and also because we are
lacking in certain things such as
information literacy and necessary
technology to fight against this
propaganda we are not able to push back
on this propaganda it's very difficult
for us to control our own narrative and
i believe he's absolutely correct
because today information is what gives
power information understanding
information being able to process
information is in fact what makes us
able to function in the contemporary
context so the fact that muslims are
lacking in this respect is a terrible
problem so we really do need to learn
things like information literacy in
order to fight against this propaganda
moving on another relevant aspect of
information literacy can be found of
course with the influence and impact of
social media so
let's read a quote here from lee
mcintyre in his book post truth which is
published by mit press and he states the
following in a recent pew poll 62
percent of u.s adults reported getting
their news from social media and 71 of
that was from facebook this means that
44 of the total adult u.s population now
gets its news from facebook this
reflects a sea of change in the source
and composition of our news content with
the decline in vetting and editing how
are we supposed to know anymore which
stories are reliable while traditional
news is still out there it's getting
harder and harder to tell what is the
well-sourced fact-driven piece and what
is not and of course some people just
prefer to read and believe news that
already fits their point of view anyway
so this is actually a massive problem
because now we're seeing a transition
from traditional news sources to social
media where largely there is no vetting
many news stories could literally be
made up and you can see people actually
sharing these things making them viral
without checking their contents we've
seen this on numerous occasions right
and i think the best example is when we
talk about myanmar now for those of you
who don't know the rohingyan genocide
was actually started on facebook and
what i mean by that is that the
unchecked propaganda against rohingya
muslims was actually initialized and
developed and evolved on facebook so the
reality is many people in myanmar were
convinced to commit genocide against the
rohingyan population based on the
propaganda they read from facebook okay
so facebook can have a great impact and
can cause a lot of problems especially
for minorities when a society is
information illiterate when they are
susceptible to being influenced by
propaganda okay so we have to be very
cognizant of this and this is still a
huge problem social media has actually
exacerbated conspiracy theories and fake
news and other such things which have
actually caused real life damage to
other people into societies at large but
there are other factors at play here not
just a lack of information literacy but
also this understanding of oneself and
the individual which makes us believe
especially from the western context
which has now become globalized in many
respects it makes us believe that one
does not need to be an expert the
democratization of knowledge as we call
it people no longer have to reference
anything people no longer have to look
up their sources everyone is perceived
especially within secular liberal
societies as having the capacity to
understand things at the same level as
those who study formally as those who
actually research these subject matters
so in other words it has become
fashionable to suffer from the
dunning-kruger effect everyone seems to
think they're a genius these days right
and this is what tom nichols discusses
in his book the death of expertise the
campaign against established knowledge
and why it matters and he says the
following these are dangerous times
never have so many people had so much
access to so much knowledge and yet have
been so resistant to learning anything
in the united states and other developed
nations otherwise intelligent people
denigrate intellectual achievement and
reject the advice of experts not only do
increasing numbers of laypeople lack
basic knowledge they reject fundamental
rules of evidence and refuse to learn
how to make a logical argument in doing
so they risk throwing away centuries of
accumulated knowledge and undermining
the practices and habits that allow us
to develop new knowledge and i think
he's precisely correct and we've
discussed the dunning-kruger effect
earlier uh and this is actually a
worldwide phenomenon uh the influence of
the democratization of knowledge by
secular liberal societies upon the rest
of the world has caused people to easily
fall for fake news and propaganda which
has also led to the rise of populism
especially in places like india and the
united states and speaking more about
this is michael patrick lynch in his
book know it all society and here he's
also writing about u.s culture and he
states the following our reliance on
google knowing turns out to feed our
natural tendency to overinflate what we
know as a psychologist matthew fisher
found in studying the relationship
between internet searches and the
illusion of explanatory depth the result
those who had searched the internet
raided their ability to know answers to
unrelated questions better than those
who had not been allowed to search the
internet merely searching the internet
convinces people that they know more
than they do even about things they
haven't researched at all it is as if
the sheer speed and ease of access of
information on the internet causes us to
lose track of how much we rely on it
thereby distorting how we view our own
abilities and that makes us think we
know more than we do so here he's
discussing the dunning-kruger effect and
the internet actually makes the problem
worse right because we have all this
access to knowledge and information we
suddenly believe that somehow now we
know as much as experts because you know
it just pops up on our screen
immediately of course without realizing
that in order to get that information
somebody who we regard as an expert has
to feed us that information yet nobody
really cares about if that person is an
expert or not so the reality is too it's
kind of ironic is that it's not so much
that people reject expertise is that
they don't care who is an expert or who
isn't they are gullible with respect to
what they're researching right so they
do accept expertise only that they're
the expert and the people who are
feeding them the information are also
experts but when you correct these
people say well that person's not a
doctor they say it doesn't matter they
don't have to be a doctor they can be an
expert anyway right so that's that's the
real problem here so it's really
significant that in today's age we have
to learn information literacy to
decipher who is actually an expert and
who is actually learned on the subject
and what expert knowledge actually looks
like okay we can't simply rely on google
to feed us the results because google
does not demarcate between expertise and
a lay person's opinion on a blog it only
demarcates between which pages are
viewed the most uh which pages are most
popular which pages are relevant to your
interest right and this is problematic
however information literacy also
assists us in other ways as well
especially when it comes to the format
and the medium of information so for
example speaking on this issue nicholas
carr writes in his book the shallows
what the internet is doing to our brains
he states the following with respect to
the nature of the material that this
information is printed on or not printed
on so he says the following a page of
online text viewed through a computer
screen may seem similar to a page of
printed text but scrolling or clicking
through a web document involves physical
actions and sensory stimuli very
different from those involved in holding
and turning the pages of a book or
magazine research has shown that the
cognitive act of reading draws not just
on our senses of sight but also on our
sense of touch it's tactile as well as
visual all reading writes ann mangen a
norwegian literary studies professor is
multi-sensory there is a crucial link
between the sensory motor experience of
the materiality of a written work and
the cognitive processing of the text
content in other words the shift from
paper to screen doesn't just change the
way we navigate a piece of writing it
also influences the degree of attention
we devote to it and our depth of
immersion so what he's trying to say
here actually is that the very material
in which this information is stored
actually causes us to be less attentive
to that information so when we examine
information in the online space in the
virtual space we are actually becoming
more attention deficit so we actually
have to put in more effort to
concentrate on the information we're
consuming online so information literacy
helps us to do that
and finally the other way in which
information literacy is relevant and
important in the contemporary period is
that it helps us to understand history
and also contemporary politics and what
do i mean by this so for example in
rosie bashir's book archive wars she
explains how the preservation of certain
documents and historical sites plays a
role in not only obviously understanding
history but also in constructing
politics so for example she states the
following historical documents archives
commemorative spaces and the built
environment are types of archives
designed to tell a certain story about
the past as well as about futures that
are in the making as forms of political
communication that knit across state and
society such technologies of knowledge
production are evidentiary networks
through which official historical
knowledge moves and becomes visible
setting the stage for future historical
narratives but they are more than just
spectacles whose salience lies in the
symbolic power they hold these monuments
are also sites of capital accumulation
that in post-war saudi arabia responded
to looming economic and financial crises
they are essential to the state's
material politics and constitute the
political economy of state making
so here she's trying to make the
argument that by preserving certain
documents and historical sites saudi
arabia is able to make an identity for
itself is able to form its own political
identity by erasing certain aspects of
the past that contradict that identity
and also forming a new future so
information literacy also helps us to
comprehend how states how nations how
cultures and even how individuals form
their own identities form their own
understanding of history and form their
own understanding of the world so this
is a more complex point here but i think
it was important to note for those who
enjoy or want to study history and
politics okay
so with that i wish to end the very
first lesson of this course and uh
before moving on um to the next lesson
you do have some homework and your
homework is the following first off
you're required to read chapter one of
your textbook especially if you want to
complete the quiz
next i want you to read justin parrott's
article on information literacy which
should be linked in either the info box
or your moodle module and you will need
to read this article very carefully
because some of the quiz questions
relate to it as well and finally if you
haven't already guessed i want you to
take the quiz now for those of you who
aren't in the moodle module but still
want to take the quiz i've actually
attached a copy in the information box
on youtube however in order to grade
yourself you're going to have to take
the quiz and then go back into the
lecture to see if the answers are
correct
because obviously there's no automatic
grading with that however you can still
download it and test your knowledge so
feel free to do so if you wish and with
that said i want to thank all of you for
your patience and time and i hope that
you learned something today jesus
christ